Book about Barry Bonds in the balco steroid scandal.
Hit store shelves today.
It is already number 24 on amazon.com bestseller list.
That's actually down one notch.
It was 23 earlier this morning,
game of shadows by two San Francisco Chronicle.
Reporters claims that bonds use steroids for at least five seasons beginning in
1998 now,
bonds denies using any banned substances and he has never tested positive for
any but one man says what is written in that book could have a huge impact on
other people,
especially impressionable young athletes.
Timothy Ferris owns a sports training and nutritional supplement company based
in San Jose.
He joins me this morning to talk about some of the concerns.
Good morning and thanks for coming.
Oh,
it's my pleasure.
Thanks for having me.
One of your concerns that this book might in your estimation,
double steroid use among,
uh,
young American athletes.
Uh,
that's exactly right.
There's a precedent of a downstream trickle effect when you have books of this
type,
particularly one is promoted as a drug by drug,
day by day account of what some people are calling the best hitter in history.
Uh,
in the late nineties,
there was a bodybuilder named Andreas Mune,
sir,
who died from an overdose of various anabolic products and a weekly German
magazine named Der Spiegel,
published all of it,
a full account with his exact dosages and when you used them,
and despite the fact that he died using this munes or cocktail as it became
known,
uh,
it was duplicated among athletes.
And that was with a relatively unknown German publication.
But this is in prime time now and I feel that,
uh,
very impressionable athletes could be led to use more,
not less steroids as a result of this bone away.
Kind of like what we see with some a movie critics.
Even if it's bad press,
any press creates more buzz and more people go to check it out.
No,
that's exactly right.
And a,
I actually have had the opportunity to read the book.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it's not as sensational as the excerpts,
but the way that the book has been positioned in the excerpts,
uh,
the sensational benefits of growth hormone,
steroids and other anabolic products far outweighs the,
uh,
the cautionary notes that are included.
So now,
as we mentioned,
you know,
you on a sports supplement company,
what do you tell your clients that they want to boost their performance?
What's your advice to them?
I work with my athletes primarily in a,
in a training and nutritional capacity,
uh,
at the highest level of sports.
Uh,
particularly in sports,
it depend on power and speed.
So track and field,
uh,
the,
the top athletes are almost without exception,
using a,
an entire laundry list of drugs.
Uh,
in my particular case,
athletes will come to me when they want to get off of those drugs,
uh,
and still maintain their competitive edge.
And that's how I assist them using hydration,
nutrition,
or botanicals in place of illegal advanced substances.
So now you're saying that most athletes are using,
when you say they use drugs,
are they illegal drugs or illegal drugs?
Uh,
they're using both.
It's,
it's that they're using purely a prescription or illegal medications.
They're using everything that they can get their hands on that will help them,
ranging from legal supplements to imported illegal schedule,
three drugs,
which,
uh,
anabolic steroids would be classified as in the same category as opium,
and with the same punishment.
Let's talk a little bit about that.
Some of the younger athletes say high school athletes and irrespective of the
book or not just the publicity,
the buzz around steroids these days,
as much attention as it gets in the media,
do you think that has any kind of an effect on them?
Do they see this and say,
I'm staying away or do they see this and get curious and go towards it in your
opinion?
I think they get curious,
uh,
particularly when they read excerpts that claim,
for example,
that growth hormone improves hand,
eye coordination,
perception,
speed,
et cetera.
Uh,
I'm not saying that the drugs don't have those effects,
but I think that education is the solution here.
A drug testing,
uh,
using drug testing to solve drugs in sports is like using a breathalyzer to
solve drunk driving.
It just doesn't work.
You need to educate these younger athletes.
And in the case of high school athletes in particular,
if you simply say don't do drugs,
uh,
it's not going to have the compelling effect that you wanted to.
You need to make it clear that given their hormonal profile at that age,
using those drugs really has no benefit.
And the downsides are tremendous.
The risks are tremendous.
When you're that age and your growth plates haven't,
uh,
haven't stopped developing.
For example,
would you say that,
that,
that follows through again,
let's say now that you're a professional athlete where you're,
you're growing has more or less come complete,
do the steroids,
are bad substances still have a negative effect in your opinion?
Uh,
they can have a negative effect,
a certain drugs more than others.
Uh,
what I think is important for people to understand is that when people say
steroids,
that's in fact a very broad class of drug.
Uh,
so if you were to say by analogy stimulant,
that would range from a cup of coffee to cocaine.
Uh,
many of these steroids have legitimate medical applications and low,
uh,
doctor supervised settings.
Um,
but when you're abusing them,
uh,
in an athletic setting using super physiological doses,
they can have very serious side effects ranging from prostate enlargement,
uh,
to,
to cardiac problems.
Um,
but I'm not going to deny the performance benefits,
that's what they're designed for.
But there are side effects and risks involved.
And if I could add one more thing,
I would say that besides the physical side effects,
uh,
people should be very aware of the legal side effects.
Most athletes,
young athletes included,
uh,
see the f the,
the drugs freely available around them and assume that means the penalties
aren't very severe.
But you can go to jail for a very long time simply by possessing these drugs,
which are very good Timothy Ferriss.
Thanks for your insight this morning.
I know it's a topic that people are going to be talking about for a long time.
It's my pleasure.
Thank you.